dans le quartier on commence à repérer
le camion du sport- tacle depuis janvier
les comédiens de terra luna tissent des
liens avec les habitants de londres à
pont à besançon la coupe à la commande
oui magnifique une coupe au centre d'un
spectacle
ce portail c'est le nom de cette
expérimentation
[Musique]
l'idée c'est de réunir la culture et le
sportif autour d'un vrai faux match de
handball et le spectacle au palais des
sports il aura lieu sur le terrain et
aussi dans les tribunes un atelier photo
vidéo fabrication de banderoles avec la
maison de quartier les habitants une
participent et le grand jour du sport
tas qu ils seront dans les tribunes du
palais des sports où habituellement ils
ne vont pas un palais qui trône au coeur
de ce quartier prioritaire
les associations jouent aussi le jeu eux
ce sont deux piliers des commerçants du
quartier dans la vie en ce moment
william ackman soldats aussi mais pour
que son commerce sur ville comme je
crois que mon commerce va tenir j'espère
que eux ils vont pouvoir tenir aussi oui
on y croit toujours
tout le monde a envie de sortir de cette
situation tout le monde a envie
d'avancer tout le monde a envie que ça
bouge
bougez s'entraîner répété tous se sont
mobilisés pour être prêt le 5 juin date
du spectacle
oui mais voilà le troisième coup chinois
est passé par là alors oui ça tombe bien
vous faites là m o c est nous sommes ur
et bien nous sommes au palais des sports
ce qui va se passer c'est que
l'événement il va être complètement
reporter il va être portée à caen et
bien il est reporté à l'automne c'est
vite rendu compte avec sébastien que le
la fenêtre de tir aliette beaucoup trop
courte et qu'il était plus sage pour le
coup de reporter mais avec la la
problématique de pouvoir comment dire
regardez les publics puisque l'intérêt
du projet s'est trahi clé publique des
quartiers des associations sur le long
terme en ce report est une grande
déception pour les sportifs et les
comédiens les deux univers les plus
touchés par la crise sanitaire des
solutions avait pourtant été trouvé pour
que le spectacle prennent forme
c'était le 7 mars les joueurs de hand
avait enfin le droit de s'entraîner me
sens toucher
on va voir aujourd'hui comment en très
peu de temps finalement on peut arriver
à faire avec des gens qui viennent
d'horizons différents une créer une
espèce de mund homogénéité pour que vous
puissiez jouer ensemble les temps morts
seront des temps par exemple qui seront
qui seront entendus de la totalité des
spectateurs au palais et sur des textes
que je vais écrire ça y est intelligent
décoller un peu de voir ça et puis c'est
ça l'énergie des vrais joueurs pour un
vrai match avec un vrai public
mais avec des comédiens pour interpréter
les coaches il se retrouvait jusqu'à
présent une fois par mois pour justement
mettre au point leur roule
finalement il faut quand même bien pour
qu'on est quand même bien là pour gagner
pour mettre des buts et puis pour
repartir avec une victoire au final mais
de belle façon le spectacle maintient le
cap sur les réseaux sociaux pour garder
le lien jeu entre couvre-feu confinement
et restrictions de metteur en scène a
déjà écrit au moins six versions de son
spectacle pour s'adapter
à la crise sanitaire suivant